what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch a
special gene Jeter promo video if you
guys are loyal subscribers you will know
that gene Jeter is one of our top reward
tier patrons for a very long time loyal
subscriber and usually he asked us to
cover one of his many kinds of videos
this gonna be sketches short films some
very unique try not to challenges and
what a lot of people don't know and this
would make sense wise they will eat a
lot of beautiful woman to appear in his
short films and such is that gene is
actually a photographer so he
photographs a lot of very beautiful
woman and he has finally unveiled he has
launched his 2020 calendar and I shared
it on the community page on YouTube by
the way guys hit a notification about
because we post a lot in the community
page these days and so yeah I'm just
really proud of the guy because this is
something he's been wanting to get done
for a long time and I shared the
commercial but I didn't react to the
commercial I haven't seen it yet because
I'm new gene wanted us to check it out
but guys there's a link in the
description box for this calendar you
know what I'm gonna buy one right now oh
snap and give it to John oh thanks man
because cuz you I don't think having a
girlfriend yep these are my hot babes
calendar she's gonna love it bode well a
couple that I will do it once a gather
now gene increase your pledge to cover
the cost of your calendar pleasure to
jeans page we're gonna get a free one
[Music]
I recognize you seen one of those
[Music]
hey Elma titillating ad Jean ah and just
as soon as it's here it's gone they're
all invited on the channel Jean that's
right they're all in but laughs I can't
wait to edit those videos I know you
live in New York but bring them all out
here fully clothed suits suits
inappropriate sheep here are a family
Friday channel all right let's break it
down meaning the pathos everything you
know people are always like Greg you
know why I love your channel because of
the fact that you guys go out of your
way when you react to actually break
things down afterwards or talk about
actually give some thoughts and opinions
well I got so many oh yeah oh yeah jeans
use of montage to demonstrate the
attractiveness of various female of
hydral fact that there are so many
different women all possess this certain
Adonis quality
yeah the hotness perhaps I think you can
be hot in all kinds of different places
outside or inside wearing clothes the
hot wearing clot music hot music as is
the best part of that I feel like Jean
you got to make your calendar with one
of those things like they do those
holiday cards with the little button and
then you open it up and it like sings a
hot song to you until you close it again
that's what you got to do with the well
how many counter hard to use but hey
gotta get those gimmicks man and maybe
also get some Lube so yeah I mean you
know people love things in bundles
family friendly loop family friendly
yeah Vaseline all the all-purpose
lubricant this is it gene you've
successfully done it after months we
have generated what I can only describe
as a dedicated product placement video
for your calendar
I know these are gonna I feel like we at
least yeah we should we should be able
to give away like stacks of these now or
something we should have like an ongoing
thing we're like weekly we just reacted
this trailer over maybe you should just
send us every month just that month were
there twelve ladies in this in this or
is this just as a preview of all the
different like did we see a glimpse of
every month
oh that's a great question gene Gino
comment below and that'll be the most
highlighted comment feel free to just
follow Jean on his YouTube channel I
guarantee everything we're fine guys do
you want Michael to shoot a calendar of
us would you buy it comment below I
should do a real rejects count sexy real
reason I gotta work out a little bit
just different expressions of our faces
yes different reaction moments the
common ones comment ones I'm always like
oh you do you do the oli you do the
cringe a lot we both like laugh with our
eyes closed and we need a new faces we
need your face got a hold we got a
rearrange the way we react to life
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
to gene Jeter's channel go get yourself
a calendar today